let's do it but borrows the gum come I
love to eat this gum this is what now
8600 to 32 years old Turkish you got
your prospective I get very upset when
people try to suppress people from
hard-working without realizing that
that's what makes that person happy and
do I believe that hard work is an
essential part of the kind of success
that people define I do do I think
working so many hours that it burns you
out that you need to retire or quit or
you're unhappy and perpetuity is bad of
course I do I think this is a
self-awareness game and actually I think
it's a much more interesting game of
like do you know why you're working or
what are you trying to achieve I would
go crazy sitting on a farm in Middle
America or doing 28 weeks of vacations
not what makes me happy but I
unbelievable I'm happy for the people
that makes it happy I love the process
of building something the way I want to
build it I think it's about
self-awareness
I think I think the cool part for me is
clouds and dirt was really the
entrepreneurial framework that I live in
which is like have your dreams and your
aspirations like live in the clouds but
if like like one thing I admire about
you and the other people that we've
given them to is like you're willing to
get in the dirt right your background of
like how you were successful speaks to
that athletically but then like as you
made the transition to an entrepreneur
and a personality like I see that in you
work ethic like not being too fancy like
putting in the [ __ ] work the dirt one
thing I try to remind people is like
talent is part of this like also for
whatever reason you were fortunate
enough to figure out a talent you had
yeah and like went all-in on it and oh
by the way you gave up your [ __ ]
childhood to do it like like everybody
thinks I'm so lucky and I'm like you're
lucky you went to high school parties
yeah I [ __ ] worked
I went home 75% of my weekends during my
college career taking Amtrak not even
[ __ ] Axela no [ __ ] first-class
[ __ ] Amtrak shooting a [ __ ] sandwich
which I kind of loved and I missed that
sandwich get get into New York not New
York not even New York which would be
fun [ __ ] Woodbridge New Jersey train
station at like eight o'clock my dad
would pick me up we drive home and then
I would wake up at 6:30 in the morning
and work in the liquor store on Saturday
and then leave back to Boston on Sunday
and now I'm lucky it's hard to it's hard
to think you're lucky when you [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] when nobody else is eating [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you look at the current state of
social media you would think that 98% of
the time in entrepreneurship it's sunny
and rosy and fun when reality it's the
reverse I mean the reality is
entrepreneurship is extremely lonely the
reality is most people spend a lot of
their times day in and day out in dark
clouds not sunshine it is you know I
always say I even make jokes when I
enter back into the country that used to
say occupation there's been times when
I've written firefighter I wake up and
expect texts of negative things like
when you own your own business
everything is your own fault
everything the business is struggling
with is your fault and you are basically
in the business of putting out negative
fires anticipating negativity getting
prepared for clouds to come over like
you're basically always looking for
shelter and umbrellas and rain boots you
are living in that and I think that
something I make fun of a lot which is
you know swans in pools in the Hamptons
and I think if swans represent fake
entrepreneurship I literally think that
worms and frogs represent real
entrepreneurship to me because I
literally think about like who comes out
when it rains a lot in Jersey as a kid I
would see frogs and worms more often
after rainstorms are during rainstorms
and I feel like those animals represent
entrepreneurship dramatically more
then that [ __ ] blown up Swan in a
fake environment during a fluffy economy
look we're all trying to achieve and
enjoy the sunshine and and the
prosperity is of it all but the reality
is disproportionately our time is spent
in navigating or anticipating dark
clouds
all right we have the Gulf a legend
right here so Gary what would you sell
these young athletes on when they want
to aspire to be something and get the
next look first of all realize how
ridiculously impossible it is I think
the biggest issue that most young
athletes have is they don't realize the
math 0.01% make it so I think one it's
not about like be practical and have a
plan B I don't believe in that
necessarily either it's just that really
be thoughtful about how much extra work
it takes like if you're not in the gym
somebody else is max here's the best
advice live your [ __ ] life and tune
out everybody else everybody out here
are so [ __ ] worried about everybody
else's opinion that you're all full of
[ __ ] on social media PR in yourself when
in reality have you got a lot of real
[ __ ] going on your head so stop [ __ ]
fronting and start living you're valuing
other people's opinions about your else
it's a scarlet letter the reason I'm
always comfortable I lose all the time I
just don't care what your comment is
about my loss ii don't care about other
people's opinions like your mom your dad
your friends your homies social media
people you told you were gonna be
successful ii don't care about anybody's
opinion second that self-doubt is ghost
because it has no value because i'm just
playing
you know I think that there's a deep
inherent understanding in my in my mind
that there's only one at-bat and I don't
want to leave anything on the table most
people don't want to work most people
didn't find what they love most people
don't have enormous ambition and most
people prefer to you to stop because it
makes them insecure while you keep
winning there's no greater gift in life
than to have the people you love be
happy and healthy the second biggest
gift in life is to [ __ ] love what you
do so much that you only want to work
[Music]
[Applause]
people struggle with contextualizing
time 28 20 years old I was in the liquor
store that's holding this event tonight
in the basement packages I worked every
day I just was patients are like like
the biggest thing is like what do you
look it's contextualizing patients the
way to get most happy is to be held
accountable for everything what do you
want everybody from 68 year old to like
the youngest person here we all can have
four years of not producing a whole lot
and still have time to do shows like I
get so pumped when people start finally
quantifying how old they really are I
think you go out here 45 years old like
thinking it's over like really 40 more
years but that's the best that's the
best part of entrepreneurship like it's
just in perpetuity
people always ask you stuff how do you
even have the how do you have that
answer for everything they ask you
because there's only like seven answers
thank you you're welcome and somewhere
along the line I realize I had something
to give like I'm kind of like good and I
have an abundance of energy and like
thoughts and like I'm thrilled to feed
it it obviously feeds me I like the
attention and the positive reinforcement
and whatever else it may be it just
feels better like I love to communicate
and I also look you know to me to be
very frank the thing that's really
brought me a lot of energy is being able
to get through to fifteen to twenty
five-year-old guys because they think
I'm cool to then push to them the
propaganda of kindness and patience and
hide work and empathy and caring I'm not
sure in the world you know this will
make sense to you based on what I've
been talking about tonight in a world
where I know when you have the right
thing squeeze it hard I may never have
another time in my career because of
what's happening on YouTube and
Instagram with me to effect what a lot
of fifteen to twenty five-year-old guys
think is the right thing to do and I
feel an enormous sense of responsibility
that I've been able to like they are the
hardest group to get through so I I feel
a huge responsibility right now and I
don't know if I'll ever have a moment
again where they're listening at this
scale and I'm very energized right now
because I know I'm making things I'm
putting things on a pedestal like
patients
you know like and so I'm really
invigorated so we did this a few weeks
back we have 1500 people watching us
live on Facebook oh yeah and across
platforms 50 other people live
watches open a 1954 boner Nickelback
what's great is I always get nervous
that you're gonna get [ __ ] and no one
cares they're like there's the [ __ ]
thrill the hostage hey Gary what's going
on bud
86 baby altoon I know the rice is what
people want but I want Alton let's
down-tuned let's do it all right here we
go
we're here at a nice restaurant Haiti
sherry be 86 Bella this is by the way
Gary this is our first ever live image
break on vacation borrow less but
borrows the gum am I allowed to eat this
come course you are I'm gonna do it this
is what now 86 get set all right Mike
quick all right
thousand-yard Club great we still love
the thousand-yard Club penny easily have
solid safety but he made the Hall of
Fame uh-huh Greg Coleman the punter I
don't remember him at all Brian Holloway
all-pro Patriot that's a problem for me
by the way
I've swallowed the gum just if there's
any confusion these are really off
Saturn Bob yes of course there's all
yours
we have you here how good is that so
this to me is like a solid psee it's a
little bit off-center Garrett but if it
was centered better Tommy so it's
[ __ ] yes exactly
that's a nice card Alice Valentine all
right
look how [ __ ] up this
oh wow sit company nice being upgraded
yeah we'll see that so we're gonna do
gyarah we're gonna grade these and
you're gonna give them out at some point
in the future to any one of your many
fans what is going to go down at the
national in Chicago this year I'm so
excited
I'm coming guns ablaze all I'm come here
where I'm out of control for four days
I'm gonna do crazy [ __ ] I'm gonna like
Drake there I'm gonna like try to break
the place brother Derek pleasure right